cette année nous invitons les
réunionnais à se mobiliser encore
davantage dans le cadre de ce 30e
téléthon a montré que bien
le défi des malades confrontés à leur
vie quotidienne aux difficultés de la
vie quotidienne
le défi de la fm au niveau de la
recherche
eh bien chacun s'empare de ce défi
chacun à la réunion de participer à une
manifestation et se lancer un défi
à quoi servent ces dons eh bien ils
servent à donner à l'afm l'association
française contre les myopathies les
moyens de développer ces deux missions
principales
c'est guérir c'est scapin de malades
guérir mais pour guérir
il faut mettre en branle la recherche
il faut mobiliser des chercheurs etc et
puis la deuxième mission c'est
accompagner les malades dans leur vie
quotidienne
pour aider les malades et leurs familles
faites un don le 2 et le 3 décembre la
réunion tel est ton pays nous défient
quand la maladie